These dragons from deep time are incredible creatures.
They're bizarre, they're beautiful, and there's very little we know about them.
These thoughts were going through my head when I looked at the pages of my first dinosaur book.
I was about five years old at the time,...
...and I decided there and then  that I would become a paleontologist.
Paleontology allowed me to combine my love for animals...
...with my desire to travel to far-flung corners of the world.
And now, a few years later,...
...I've led several expeditions to the ultimate far-flung corner on this planet, the Sahara.
I've worked in the Sahara...
...because I've been on a quest to uncover new remains...
...of a bizarre, giant predatory dinosaur called Spinosaurus.
A few bones of this animal have been found in the deserts of Egypt...
...and were described about 100 years ago by a German paleontologist.
Unfortunately, all his Spinosaurus bones were destroyed in World War II,...
...so all we're left with are just a few drawings and notes.
From these drawings, we know that this creature,...
...which lived about 100 million years ago, was very big.
It had tall spines on its back, forming a magnificent sail,...
...and it had long, slender jaws, a bit like a crocodile, with conical teeth,...
...that may have been used to catch slippery prey, like fish.
But that was pretty much all we knew about this animal for the next 100 years.
My fieldwork took me to the border region between Morocco and Algeria,..
...a place called the Kem Kem.
It's a difficult place to work in.
You have to deal with sandstorms and snakes and scorpions,...
...and it's very difficult to find good fossils there.
But our hard work paid off.
We discovered many incredible specimens.
There's the largest dinosaur bone that had ever been found in this part of the Sahara.
We found remains of giant predatory dinosaurs,...
...medium-sized predatory dinosaurs...
...and seven or eight different kinds of crocodile-like hunters.
These fossils were deposited in a river system.
The river system was also home to a giant, car-sized coelacanth, a monster sawfish,...
...and the skies over the river system were filled with pterosaurs, flying reptiles.
It was a pretty dangerous place,...
...not the kind of place where you'd want to travel to if you had a time machine.